good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight we're starting to learn
the identities of some of the large but
still own unknown number of americans in
the low hundreds they've assured us who
were abandoned by the us military this
week and remain trapped in taliban
controlled afghanistan the sacramento
bee has just reported that at least two
dozen students enrolled in the san juan
unified school district in the state of
california are stranded somewhere in
afghanistan tonight no one's certain
where they are or how they're going to
get home the white house hasn't bothered
to comment despite being asked
what's so interesting the contrast that
informs us really is that over the past
week this same administration has
overseen the evacuation of tens of
thousands of unvetted afghan nationals
many of whom will now be moved into
neighborhoods around the united states
and stay permanently
they didn't seem to encounter any
problems in doing this thanks to
meticulous and thoughtful planning
operation change america forever came
off precisely according to plan it
worked flawlessly
but a couple of dozen american school
kids trapped in afghanistan the white
house isn't really interested in what
happens to them so they pass that
portfolio to tony blinken which tells
you how completely unimportant they
consider it quote if there's an american
citizen left in afghanistan joe biden
told us the other day we're going to
stay until we get them all out
right
he didn't mean that
so what's tony blinken's plan to get
them all out to rescue the american
citizens trapped tonight in afghanistan
well as blinken told us yesterday the
governments of haiti and the republic of
congo have sent a strongly worded letter
to the taliban and beware they mean it
you wouldn't want to see the republic of
congo when it's mad
that's the kind of weak it's been
whenever you think we have reached peak
insanity they double down
this afternoon the supposed president of
the united states appeared out of
nowhere and decided to speak in public
did you see it
how to describe the experience exactly
weird is just the beginning
so first off for example biden announced
that the united states is done with
afghanistan forever we're gone and we're
not coming back ever
then biden angrily announced that we'd
quote hunt down something called isis k
which sounds suspiciously like a new
line of cosmetics from kim kardashian
but apparently isn't
this isis k biden said may be hiding in
afghanistan in which case we will hunt
them down there in afghanistan
so actually we're not really leaving
afghanistan we could be back very soon
the whole speech was like that it was
disorienting
at one point biden bragged about what a
remarkably really a stunningly and
historically successful military and
intelligence operation we have just
witnessed all of us together
apparently biden is under the impression
that the entire united states has lost
electrical power and no one has a
working internet connection so this is
what he said we completed one of the
biggest airlifts in history with more
than 120 000 people evacuated to safety
that number is more than double
what most experts thought were possible
no nation
no nation has ever done anything like it
in all of history
the only the united states
had the capacity and the will and
ability to do it and we did it today
the extraordinary success of this
mission
was due to the incredible skill
bravely
and selfless courage of the united
states military and our diplomats
and intelligence professionals
so no nation is in history has ever done
anything like this yeah possible
but he didn't mean it like that he's
telling us that this was the berlin
airlift plus d-day plus the moon shot
plus the invention of yoga pants this
was a triumph of american brilliance and
ingenuity and will
50 years from now your grandchildren
will celebrate fall of kabul day with
tears of pride in their eyes my
ancestors did that they'll think
as we said it was demented it was
literally demented
but over at the white house they seem to
believe every word of it they are losing
consciousness from huffing their own
fumes watch biden continue
the bottom line
90
of americans in afghanistan who wanted
to leave were able to leave
yeah
by going on to repeat what tony blinken
told us yesterday which is the taliban
will probably allow those remaining 10
of americans to leave at some point
possibly he didn't explain why the
taliban would allow this or why we
should be certain that they will allow
it in fact he did the opposite in the
same speech that he praised the
intelligence communities extraordinary
success joe biden admitted in the same
speech that yes the intelligence
community the extraordinarily successful
intelligence community completely missed
the fact that afghanistan's government
would fall apart in a weekend
that assumption
that the afghan government would be able
to hold on
for a period of time beyond military
drawdown
turned out not to be accurate
turned out not to be accurate the
president of afghanistan who was a
college professor hand-picked by the
college professors who run our
government the conspiracy of morons
running the world
that guy fled the country in an hour
without telling anybody including his
handlers at the cia they had no idea but
that was an extraordinary success
says joe biden nothing could have been
done to avoid the disaster that you have
watched to avoid the images you're
seeing on your screen right now that
would be the taliban dressed up as
american soldiers checking out the
helicopters we left for them
we had no choice but to leave
90 billion dollars of sophisticated
military equipment to the taliban we
armed the taliban 20 years after we
arrived in afghanistan to beat the
taliban back to the stone age they're
now one of the best armed militaries in
the world
and that was a great success
why didn't the buy administration figure
out how to take this equipment with us
or at least destroy it
no one's answered that question but the
key thing is
they're not ashamed by it at all in fact
now they're telling us they want to give
the taliban more aid direct cash
payments sounds like we're making this
up every night we think will people
believe the script yeah because it's
real
watch the national security advisor the
road scholar jake sullivan explain it
today when it comes to our economic and
development assistance relationship with
the taliban that will be about the
taliban's actions it will be about
whether they follow through on their
commitments their commitments to safe
passage for americans and afghan allies
their commitment to not allow
afghanistan to be
a base from which terrorists can attack
the united states or any other country
their commitments with respect to
upholding their international
obligations it's going to be up to them
and and we will wait and see by their
actions how we end up responding uh in
terms of the economic and development
assistance
you got to think the taliban are sitting
around their teapot gazing up at cnn
from their carpets and thinking
that kid is the national security
advisor for the great satan
maybe it's not so great you really think
they take jake sullivan seriously those
of us who were born in the united states
wouldn't even consider taking jake
sullivan seriously for a second you
couldn't count on that kid to get your
starbucks order right and he's
threatening the taliban we're not going
to give you more aid he's given them 90
billion they've one of the biggest air
forces in the region
right so the buy administration is not
going to admit anything and the key
thing they're not going to admit is that
we just left a whole lot of american
citizens including school children in a
country we turned over to barbarians
with a history of killing americans
no one's going to admit that instead the
geniuses the road scholars are going to
treat the taliban like the rest of our
allies which means paying them a lot of
your money and telling you that they're
doing what we tell them to do when
they're not
so what we're witnessing is a total lack
a total and profound and obvious lack of
accountability on the part of the people
making decisions that affect your life
and that have ended the lives of many
americans
this bothers people doesn't matter who
you voted for in the last election
that's not an acceptable system and the
people who are bothered most not
surprisingly are the ones who just lost
their sons in kabul
mark schmitz had a son called jared who
was killed in the kabul bombing he's met
with joe biden here's what he said quote
i'm not trying to insult the president
but it just didn't seem that appropriate
to spend that much time on his own son
when you're the one responsible for
ultimately the way things went down you
kind of feel like that person should own
it a little more yeah you think
lecturing is about his own son with
nothing to do with afghanistan with all
respect when you stop talking about
yourself for a minute and apologize to
the people whose sons you got killed
last week we talked to the father of one
of the marines who was killed in the
bombing in kabul kareem nikui's was his
name that marine's mother shane chapel
just posted a message for joe biden on
facebook it ended this way quote you
turned to walk away and i let you know
my son's blood was on your hands
okay she's a grieving mother her son was
just killed
facebook
in response
censored her instagram which facebook
owns deleted her account entirely and
that's what happens when you contradict
the head of the democratic party that
elderly man wagging his finger in your
face from the white house telling you
how to raise your kids
what we just saw in afghanistan was a
military triumph you must agree
or we will make you disappear if you go
along with it you can go on cnn watch
he needs to do his job competently and
well which so far i think he's done it's
proved i mean he's done what what nobody
thought possible so far on covet
obviously he's faced with a delta
variant and trying to make that work
better i think the afghanistan thing
went way better than most people
expected two weeks ago
what's funny is that that guy
who's got a track record of failure
decades long is one of the geniuses who
put us in afghanistan in the first place
and then lied to the american public
about it for many many years his name is
matthew dowd he's never apologized for
that and said he's doubled down calling
anyone who disagrees with anything he or
any of the politicians he's worked for
he's called them
unpatriotic what makes this all even
more nauseating is that the biden
administration appears to agree with it
they're not even self-aware enough to
know how badly they have failed they
have no capacity for self-reflection as
if to prove that the state department
spokesman just tweeted out a column from
jennifer rubin the dumbest person ever
to work for the washington post about
what a great job they're doing here's
the headline quote the state department
deserves more credit for its effort to
evacuate americans from afghanistan
[Laughter]
the column does concede that yes there
are americans trapped in afghanistan yes
they were abandoned by the u.s military
which exists to protect them but it
didn't for some reason quote it is
possible some of the 250 might not make
it out could some americans face
physical abuse absolutely it's like
animal house other things we did wrong
sure
but on the flip side jen rubin says
quote the herculean effort to extract
thousands of americans after the taliban
seized control of the country should not
go unnoticed or unappreciated notice the
double negative the hallmark of the
[ __ ] but it's not just dummal gen ruben
it's what the state department believes
those are the people the pentagon now
tells us are in charge of rescuing those
school kids from afghanistan
as americans wonder how to get home
because they've been abandoned
these people are congratulating
themselves and that should not surprise
us because it's exactly what the
pentagon has been doing for decades with
no repercussions whatsoever this is the
secretary of defense in 2011.
and what you've accomplished
is extraordinary because over the last
year essentially you have ejected
the taliban from their
from their home territory
and if we can hold this territory and
expand the bubble
then i think
i think by the end of the year we can
turn the corner in this conflict
well the end of the year would have been
let's see about well exactly 10 years
ago so we don't mean to single out that
guy who's probably one of the smarter
people to oversee this disaster for the
last 20 years only to point out that
this disaster did not start 10 days ago
it started in october of 2001.
the taliban was ejected
if you're getting the sense that the
same people have been reading the same
script for two decades you're on to
something and they're still still doing
it right now today they're pretending
everything is fine watch as the
pentagon's top spokesman explains that
yes americans are trapped in kabul but
that's really no different from when
american tourists and see
the caribbean lose their passports
it's not completely unlike the way we do
it elsewhere around the world i mean we
have americans that get stranded in
countries all the time and we do
everything we can to try to facilitate
safe passage
so let's say you're on a water slide in
the bvi and somehow your blue passport
it's kind of like that if you're in
kandahar when the taliban take over
so you get oily creatures like the one
you just saw
when institutions are
not held accountable for their bad
decisions for like let's say 20 years
they can say whatever they want no
matter how ridiculous no matter how
absurd and they know
there will be no repercussions
today joe biden had the opportunity to
punish the people who've been
responsible for these failures
for more than 20 years instead he called
the whole thing an extraordinary success
he mentioned his son beau for some
reason and after he was done with his
prepared remarks he just walked away
enterprising reporters shouted questions
and for a moment it appeared possible
that joe biden might answer them he
turned back and walked toward the podium
then we realized he'd just forgotten his
little obedience mask so he grabbed it
and walked away hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else